lovely to be here it is lovely uh we're
actually here to do two things the first
is to raise awareness about the vital
importance of using a good moisturizer
Andy has been wearing one every day for
the last 29 years I've never used one in
my life
still stunning basically a scrotum
the second
the second is to celebrate the role of
the production designer in the making of
a great movie what are you doing
these unsung Geniuses armed with World
building imaginations that sometimes
succeed all budgets create new
environments from thin air
and here are the nominees for
achievement in production design All
Quiet on the Western Front production
design by Christiane M Goldberg set
decoration by Ernestine hipper
Avatar the way of Water Production
designed by Dylan Cole and Ben Proctor
set decoration by Vanessa Cole
Babylon production designed by Florencia
Martin set decoration by Anthony carlino
foreign
[Music]
production designed by Catherine Martin
and Karen Murphy set decoration by Bev
Dunn
[Music]
the fablemans production design by Rick
Carter set decoration by Karen O'Hara
oh thank you and the Oscar goes to
all quiet
Christian M Goldberg production design
Ernestine pepper set decoration
[Applause]
thank you so much to your Academy I'm
completely blown away I would like to
thank first of all our beautiful
director Edward Berger without you I
could have not done it
this whole thing was a real team effort
my my heart goes out to all the other
hods who worked on this project I could
have not done it without you
Malta grunard thank you to to take me on
this show
absolute pleasure
and
first of all I want
to give this to my two beautiful sons
Zebedee and Gustav thank you
this is I have to thank my parents Mama
Papa I love you and my sisters and my
dear friends
and
um
when I started this I was told Ernestine
whenever don't ever forget you're only
as good as your team so this is to all
the hard-working people in Prague
and all the teams that helped me to get
on this stage and Academy and everybody
thank you so much this is so I'm so
honored thank you
[Music]